en el último vídeo empezamos a hablar de
cómo parametrizar un toro o la figura de
lo que es una dona y los parámetros que
estábamos usando gastamos mucho tiempo
tratando de visualizarlo porque todo se
trata de la visualización así que yo
creo que la parte difícil ya la hemos
pasado y ahora podemos parametrizar el
toro que es la superficie de esta zona
como lo había dicho y lo que vamos a
hacer es tomar puntos en este círculo y
vamos a rotar los vamos a rotar los
alrededor del eje z muy bien vamos a
utilizar este parámetro s que puede ir
entre 0 y 2 pi para decir que tanto se
separe el ángulo del plano xy ok y eso
nos determina este círculo y luego
rotamos alrededor del eje z así que
siempre vamos a estar guardando una
distancia ve al centro de los círculos y
después definimos el parámetro de verdad
que era lo que nos decía que tanto rota
vamos alrededor de él
gz y esos eran nuestras dos definiciones
de parámetros y luego intentamos
visualizar qué pasaba con este tipo de
dominio en nuestro en nuestra
parametrización nombre es decir qué pasa
con ese entre 0 y 2 para que también
entre 0 y 2 pi y como iba rotando todas
estas estas figuras por ejemplo poniendo
esa igual a 0 teníamos un círculo
después de igual a cero pues nos daba
todo un un círculo que es una sección
transversal poniéndote perdón ese igual
y medios teníamos en la circunferencia
superior en fin todo esto estaba en
nuestro espacio x y z es decir en el
espacio de tres dimensiones y ahora
espero que podamos visualizarlo muy bien
porque vamos a definir la posición de
obama definir una función de valores
vectoriales que nos da la posición en la
superficie y esto a partir de la
parametrización así que vamos a irnos
derechitos a eso vamos a ver esto de
aquí cuál es nuestra zeta como una
función de s
bueno realmente todas nuestras variables
x jay-z van a ser funciones de aceite
pero la más fácil de obtener es la z
miren vamos a ver lo que estamos viendo
aquí es que en este punto déjenme poner
este par de puntos ok
estamos representando estos puntos
azules respectivamente entonces el punto
azulito corresponde
el punto azulito el amarillo al amarillo
y puedo hacer más digamos déjenme elegir
este punto aquí es igual a 0
y él te iguala y medios corresponde a
este morado que estoy pintando vamos a
definir uno más para ver el cuadro
entonces este verde es ese igual aquí
medios de igual a cero corresponde a
este verde así que para ese y te estamos
mapeando puntos en el espacio x y z
así que z x y deben ser funciones de ese
y t
la primera que vamos a pensar es la zeta
como les dije ésta es bastante bastante
fácil así que z como función de aceite a
que va a ser igual bueno vamos a ver si
tomamos un círculo recordemos que ese es
el ángulo en el que se separan digamos
el plano xy entonces puedo dibujarlo
déjenme hacerlo con otro color
se me están acabando los colores así que
digamos que este radio tiene un ángulo s
muy bien entonces si lo pintamos de esta
forma digamos aquí por la parte entonces
sólo necesitamos hacer un poco de
trigonometría verdad tenemos este ángulo
ese y lo que queremos calcular bueno
sabemos el radio el radio está así lo
habíamos definido y se está va a ser
simplemente la distancia de la altura de
este triángulo verdad que es la
distancia del punto al plano x y eso es
trigonometría básica ese es directa
porque podemos utilizar las propiedades
de las funciones trigonométricas y si no
te la das no si no te acordás de ellas
quizás debas repasar esos vídeos así que
z que es la altura
digamos podemos utilizar la relación del
seno verdad seno de ese seno de ese es
igual al cateto opuesto que z entre
hipotenusa que es y ahora multiplicamos
ambos lados por a y obtenemos que a por
seno de ese es zeta y eso nos dice que
y altos estamos con respecto del plano
xy pura trigonometría así que z que
depende de aceite va a ser a seno de ese
ok no dependió de t pero podemos pensar
que que si depende que si depende aunque
no está explícitamente ahí ahora lo que
vamos a intentar es descubrir quién es x
y quién es y ok entonces realmente la
zeta no dependió de en qué posición
andamos de xy de y realmente sólo
depende del ángulo que hacemos con ese
plano verdad con el plano de xy entonces
realmente por ejemplo al variar xy ya
sólo le estamos dando la vuelta al al al
toro sin mover nuestro valor 7 entonces
espero que esto tenga mucho sentido para
ustedes ahora vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando vamos girando es decir vamos a
ver qué pasa con x y vamos a ver esta
imagen de la dona así que el centro el
centro de cada uno de los círculos está
a una distancia ve del eje z
y cuando lo vamos rotando
esta distancia siempre es be así que
nuestra coordenada x y van a depender y
van a estar relacionadas con la
distancia al eje z entonces vamos a ver
como como podemos ver esta distancia
digamos realmente el punto en el toro
que queremos ver es imaginemos que
proyectamos este punto este punto sobre
el plano xy
cómo se vería bueno vamos a regresar nos
a un dibujo esto debería ser más visible
este es un ejemplo particular del
círculo verdad entonces dibujamos el eje
z y el eje z
y ahora pintamos este es este radio ve
que sabemos que existe entonces cuál
cuál va a ser esa distancia bueno va a
ser toda esta toda esta es la que
queremos encontrar ok y sabemos que al
centro de este círculo es b dependiendo
del ángulo ese es como vamos a tener la
distancia así que si estás en el plano
xy vamos a encontrar que depende la
distancia de ese ya que vamos a sumar la
distancia en que es digamos de proyectar
el radio sobre el plano x 10 y sumarle b
pero entonces vamos a tener que usar una
relación trigonométricas es decir a por
el coseno de s es lo que nos da esta
distancia en morado está que estoy
pintando ahora en amarillo esa distancia
y ahora hay que sumarle
tenemos que sumarle está otra vez verdad
esa es nuestra distancia del eje al
punto proyectado en xy entonces tenemos
que la distancia es b más a coseno de s
si por ejemplo tenemos ese de este lado
entonces el coste no lo que va a estar
haciendo es reducir reducir la distancia
verdad porque coseno para un ángulo
mayor que pi medios es negativo entonces
todo esto tiene sentido ahora si nos
encontramos aquí
esta es la distancia que estamos
encontrando hace unos momentos no esto
es el b más a coseno de s
esto es b coseno de masako seno de s
esa es la distancia que tenemos en el
plano xy realmente lo que queremos ver
es ahora descomponerlo tanto en x como
en 10 ok esto es lo que ya hemos dicho
estos temas a coseno de ese es para que
lo puedan ver en distintos en distintas
figuras
vamos a encontrar ahora quien es x y
entonces ahora sí estamos viendo justo
desde desde una perspectiva desde arriba
digamos como si estuviéramos volando
podemos determinar bien quién es xy
porque vamos a dibujar otro triángulo
rectángulo verdad aquí el ángulo este la
altura va a ser equis y la base va a
serie así que ya lo tenemos porque
podemos seguir utilizando propiedades
trigonométricas para encontrar nuestra
coordenada x como función de aceite
digamos x en este caso es la altura y
cómo se calcula la altura bueno esto
simplemente es por trigonometría seno de
t que este es el ángulo t por el radio
por el radio o la hipotenusa que es b
más a coseno de s
muy bien ahora recordemos que todo esto
depende de en qué punto andemos del
círculo verdad es decir si depende de
qué tanto estamos girando nos ente y
bueno ahora lo que falta es calcular
nuestra variable y porque ya encontramos
x como función de aceite ya encontramos
hace está y ahora lo que hay que hacer
es encontrar nuestra y así que bueno de
hecho déjenme ver que en el dibujo lo
que hice fue definir la parte positiva
de x hacia arriba que es en el lado
contrario de donde pinte el eje verdad
así que espero esto no les no les
confunda mucho y haga mucho sentido pero
bueno depende también de cómo usen su
orientación que la regla de la mano y
demás bueno éste lo que importa es que
ya encontramos la fórmula para x ahora
vamos a tener vamos a echar un vistazo a
esto esto es un corte del toro
un corte del toro y esto lo que nos dice
es qué tan lejos estamos del eje en el
plano xy estamos retomando un poco luego
hicimos la proyección y a partir de la
proyección hicimos este último triángulo
que nos permitió calcular x en términos
de aceite ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con
ye que es esta base entonces ya que
depende de aceite en esta ocasión va a
tener que relacionarse con el coseno dt
que multiplica también al radio es decir
que multiplica a b más a coseno de s b
más a coseno de s y así nuestra
parametrización ya está hecha y espero
haga sentido todo esto digo si tienes
aquí tu coordenada y en realidad lo que
estamos haciendo es la propiedad de la
trigonometría del perdón de la función
trigonométricas coseno de verdad que es
cateto adyacente interés entre
hipotenusa que es de entre de masako
seno de s
simplemente estamos multiplicando a
ambos lados por b masako seno de s y es
lo que nos da esta relación que
obtuvimos aquí del lado derecho entonces
déjenme copiar y pegar esto
copiamos
y vamos a pegarlo acá y ya tenemos lista
nuestra parametrización verdad tenemos a
x ayer ya z como función de aceite
pudimos dejarlo así pero bueno queremos
una representación vectorial de la
posición así que podemos definirlo de
esta forma con un color bonito como rosa
r que es nuestra posición en el toro va
a depender también de ese y de t
entonces esto va a ser igual a en la
primera coordenada va a ser
déjenme hacerlo con el mismo color va a
ser ve más a coseno de ese coseno ds por
seno de t simplemente invertir el orden
y esta es nuestra primera entrada
entonces multiplica al vector vector al
vector y que es el vector unitario en la
dirección x entonces este es nuestro
vector y ok vamos en esa dirección y así
es como hemos definido estas cosas ahora
le sumamos la componente y que va a ser
de más a coseno de s demás a coseno de s
y multiplicada coseno dt en la dirección
del vector unitario j muy bien y
finalmente bueno recordemos que el
vector unitario jota va en dirección del
eje y es verdad es ese último que pinte
finalmente la componente en zeta que es
la más fácil de obtener verdad que es a
seno de ese que multiplica el vector
que es el que va en el vector unitario
en la dirección zeta este de arriba muy
bien así que ahora que tú me des aceite
en el dominio que hemos definido acá
arriba en este cuadrado entonces una vez
que tú me das aceite yo te puedo decir
en qué posición se encuentra el punto
sobre el toro esto asocia correctamente
un punto en el toro cada uno de los
puntos de este cuadro corresponderá bajo
la función a un punto del toro así que
ya sea que le pongas primeros cero y
cuartos lo que tú quieras tú lo
sustituyen y ahí te arroja un valor en
el toro entonces en este caso por
ejemplo en la posición en medios como
medios esto es además a coseno de pi
medios pero coseno y medios es cero
verdad y luego
esto nos quedaba más 0 por el seno de pi
medios pero seno de medios es 1 por lo
tanto sólo nos queda b que multiplica el
vector y ahora en la siguiente ve más a
coseno depp y medios bueno conocer 9
medios también se hace 0 así que nos
quedaba por el coseno de medios pero con
senodep y medio se anula así que toda
esta componente en jota va a ser cero
cero j
y finalmente en la componente zeta
tenemos a por el seno de pi medios pero
seno de medios es 1 así que simplemente
tendremos más a por acá así que no hay
una componente en la dirección j así que
simplemente será b y más a k
así que el punto que especifica es nos
movemos una cantidad de ve en la
dirección y entonces nos movemos a esta
dirección
y digamos de unidades y luego le sumamos
a la altura verdad que está justo aquí
este es el vector que corresponde a
cuando evaluamos en ese ítem y medios
por supuesto puedo seguir agarrando
puntos fáciles de calcular pero lo que
quiero que vean es que todo este dominio
de la izquierda va a cubrir bajo la
transformación a toda la superficie y
esta es la regla de correspondencia y
por supuesto cuando damos esta función
vectorial tenemos que especificar entre
qué valores se mueven los parámetros por
ejemplo ese está entre 0 y 2 pi y por
supuesto que también nuestro parámetro t
está entre 0 y 2 pi
si consideramos dos parámetros en ese
lugar tendremos un punto en el toro
así que ya estamos hablando podríamos
hablar de superficies verdad de algunas
áreas cuando acotemos aceite entre otros
intervalos pero bueno lo que estamos
haciendo nos servirá para las integrales
de superficie lo más difícil ha sido
esto la visualización nos vemos